fascination moderator and CBS News
senior foreign affairs correspondent
Margaret Brennan is here the former
Deputy Secretary of State under
President Obama William burns is with us
as well he also served as ambassador to
Russia from 2005 to 2008 and met
President Vladimir Putin while in that
role good morning to you both ambassador
burns let me start with you you said
that the the best thing that can happen
from this meeting is that it would be
Hippocratic which is to say the
Hippocratic oath first do no harm so
what would that look like
well I think first it means it's
essential that the president made clear
to President Putin that the election
meddling which was documented in the
indictments last week is a major assault
on our democracy and that it's very
serious business I think it means not
succumbing to the illusion that personal
rapport can transform relationships or
that there are grand bargains to be done
out there and third I think you can
focus on a few practical steps specially
in arms control where the new start
agreement on strategic nuclear weapons
expires in a couple of years and that's
a conversation we should resume with the
Russians that personal rapport point it
seems something that is that something
that every president kind of has to
learn I remember he previous in
administration's for example when George
W Bush came into office they said we're
not going to fall for just this cozy
relationship with a Russian leader there
are interests separate and apart from
these personal relationships well
personal relationships obviously matter
but they got to be tethered to history
to a sense of what it is that you want
to accomplish this isn't just about
getting along with another leader it's
about pursuing American interests and
that's what you got to keep them focused
resident Trump in the past has always
blamed his predecessors for the reason
that the relationship between Russia and
the u.s. is so bad is that a fair
criticism I don't think it is I mean in
the tweet the president sent out this
morning he was basically saying that not
only are relations at low ebb since the
end of the Cold War but it's basically
his predecessors fault and that also is
not tethered to history in the sense
that it ignores the fact that you know
of Russia's aggression in Ukraine in
2014 that's intervention in Syria in
2015 and it's interference in our
elections in 2016
Margaret the opening comments that we
just heard from the two presidents
President Trump said that he will ask
Vladimir Putin a lot of questions
aren't we past the part of asking
questions that happened at their last
meeting don't we need answers right now
in a response in terms of the election
mentally yes well I mean as the
president said what do you expect a
Perry Mason moment he seems to be sort
of dismissing this idea that a
confrontation is what is really needed
even though he prides himself on tough
talk the question I think is sort of he
wants to turn the page he wants
something he can put the Trump brand on
in terms of a new deal whether it's arms
control or whether it's some kind of
breakthrough in Syria or in Ukraine the
concern as diplomats that said to me
leading up to this is let's just have
our fingers crossed that NATO is good
enough and he doesn't give Putin
anything what does that mean they're
concerned perhaps could he call off
military exercises in the Baltic
something like what he did when he met
with the North Korean leader recently
calls something off without getting
anything in return from Vladimir Putin
could he do something like recognizes
annexation of Crimea which despite the
denials of US officials on the record
they will say off the record yes he has
opened the door to that and why does
that matter because you are then
blessing the seizure of territory by for
something that international law has you
know been established to try to prevent
those kind of things so I don't expect
the President to go in with a
confrontation on that but as major
Garrett pointed out the Trump
administration on paper does have a
tough policy a hard-line position
against Russia whether it's liquefied
national natural gas as he laid out
whether its arms to Ukraine it just
hasn't been backed up by what the
president actually says ambassador what
do you make of this the difference of
the styles between the two men
I think the the format of this summit
we're you know one on one meeting is
sort of a centerpiece of it you know
very loosely prepared summit is a big
contrast of summits I've known over the
last thirty years where there are
one-on-one meetings but they're a small
part of a very carefully planned sum at
first second you know you have a
president President Trump who prides
himself on winning
operating from his guys I don't think
flirting where Putin never wings yes you
know he
he has his own well practiced narrative
about what's happened over the last 20
almost 20 years since he's been
president he's deeply experienced and so
he's going to try to take advantage of
that and take advantage of his command
of detail and he has an advantage I
think he does in the sense that he's a
vastly experienced leader I think he's
not at all sentimental about personal
rapport he can charm as well as bully
and I think you'll see a lot of charm
from him and the one-on-one meeting with
President Roh and you have professionals
like the Ambassador to protect a
president even though he says he doesn't
want to trust the bureaucracy under
normal circumstances but not here thanks
to both Margaret and ambassador burns